si l'immigré aussi presque tous à
domicile est ce que je suis déterminé
boulot ça existait écoutez si on faisait
le tour de ses de ce plateau et on
lisait la biographie de chacun on
verrait que nous sommes que nous portons
certains d'entre nous des noms étrangers
là je le sais je viens aux tunisiens
alors si on veut on verrait déjà que
nous sommes tous ceux qui ont cette
biographie nous sommes intégrés
nous ne sommes pas au rsa nous avons
fait des études
nous nous sommes à des postes honorable
voyez à part moi à part vous mais oui
vous est trop modeste pour faire
mépriser les gens viennent nous écouter
m allait-on ses fantasmes à mépriser
mauvais c'est la première fois que la
victime voulait saisir vos fantasmes je
vais vous donner les vrais chiffres
d'eurostat
c'est pas moi qui les ai pris alors
aujourd'hui en france la peau la
proportion d'étrangers et de 4,6 pouces
à 7 ou de clamer depuis 50 ans c'est
l'avenir du cinéma c'est fou je veux
qu'on s'enrichit festayres les sources
les sushis qu'elle 0,3 pour cent en
allemagne
je vais arrêter mais chief là vous voilà
c'est cette émigration à vingt six ans
de français d'origine étrangère qui vous
plaît laissez la fille ces crapules qui
sont français mais ça me sens pas que le
grès d'immigration
ici mais laissez nous parler les
hestayres ça suffit quoi voilà en écoute
sur terre
en fait les gens se vole alors on
défonce 12h16 2018 il y avait 250 scène
5000 personnes qui ont tu leurs papiers
d'accord trente cinq mille demandes
d'asile et que notre vin dit bill et tu
fais honte et non le cema fine et
vanilla l'accouchement familiale 32000
économique et 90 1082 mines étudiants
alors il n'y a pas de quoi
n'est ce pas être submergé par c'est
l'équivalent la ville de toulouse qui
avait chaque année il vient annoncer
rien
de personnes chaque année la
viabilisation
mais le problème c'est l'accueil non non
non non savons pas accueillir la
bouillante et vous allez je dois quand
même mais c'est pas possible pour faire
des contre vérités en tabac non c'était
les élèves désormais cpe machisme
annoncé l'armée la chanteur s'est pas au
bas des immeubles
il ne serait pas comme à la porte
d'aubervilliers où j'ai été lundi il ya
des familles qui ont des papiers
messieurs alors ils ont dévissé
oui dit de séjour ils sont dans des
igloos avec des enfants on ne la sent
pas bien écouté la majorité avaient
dépeint enfin ton du monde et du bling
ou descendez sur la seule place à vous
atterri sur l'île faut se rendre à
verser 1
ban appelle massa du sénat mais les
centres de rétention le temps de
rétention fait les campements mais oui
je ne raconte pas de bêtises vous êtes à
opérer et waterloo oak racing et vous
plaît s'il vous plaît
hélas la même massa